bonjour pas normalement j'ai des styles
je sais pas s'ils vont s'afficher
voilà alors déjà je suis très content
d'être à grenoble je suis né à grenoble
donc je suis un peu l'un des vôtres et
je suis vraiment content de retourner à
la racine aux sources
voilà alors en patinage artistique le
tirage au sort c'est extrêmement
important
voilà j'ai tiré le numéro deux derrière
max c'est un peu dommage pour moi parce
qu'il a extrêmement bien parlé il m'a
mis la pression
c'est difficile pour moi alors
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de parler
d'apprentissage j'ai pris une citation
enfin la première partie d'une citation
de anton tchekhov les gens intelligents
et m'apprendre je suis je suis un peu
moins d'accord avec la deuxième partie
de la citation vous vous irez la voir si
vous voulez sur internet ou si vous
voulez n'y allez pas en tout cas je les
censurer parce que je pense que les
moins intéressantes
et puis après réflexion au fait comme
dans quelques minutes je vais dire que
j'adore apprendre que j'apprends tout le
temps je me finalement c'est pas trés
c'est pas très humble à cette citation
donc donc je me suis permis d'ajouter
une deuxième citation on se lasse de
tout excepté d'apprendre voilà alors
qu'y apprend bas tout le monde
évidemment vous apprenez et mais je
pense que ceux qui veulent apprendre le
plus c'est vraiment ceux qui ont le plus
ambitions ce qu'on vit le plus de
réussir et le plus de progresser alors
effectivement je vais revenir rapidement
sur mon parcours c'est là où je parle à
la fois du parcours de sportif de haut
niveau et du parcours d'étudiants et de
professionnels maintenant comme max moi
j'ai eu un double parcours donc
effectivement c'était le sport et les
études
j'ai toujours privilégié les études je
suis arrivé un peu par hasard au niveau
en sport parce que parce que j'aimais ça
tout simplement
j'aimais patiner et au final j'ai
toujours voulu apprendre plus plus de
choses plus d'éléments à faire c'était
un vrai plaisir pour moi et finalement
la démarche entre un sportif de haut
niveau et un étudiant de haut niveau ou
un professionnel de haut niveau c'est la
même seulement après la restitution ca
les différentes le sportif restitue par
le corps ce qu'il a appris
l'étudiant c'est plus par l'esprit par
les cris parlera à l'essai mais au final
vraiment les démarches sont les mêmes et
c'est ce qui m'a poussé à reprendre si
une citation de meriem salmi une
psychologue avec qui j'ai travaillé à
l'insep qui dit un sportif de haut
niveau est extrêmement intelligent
alors je vous rassure elle a entendu
parler franck ribéry mais mais il ya
différentes types d'intelligence il ya
la capacité d'adaptation l'intelligence
émotionnelle et ça c'est des qualités
qui sont vraiment nécessaires aux
sportifs de haut niveau
alors aujourd'hui j'aurais pu parler de
mon parcours d'étudiant mais je pense
qu'il est un peu moins intéressant pour
vous savez ce que c'est qu'un étudiant
de cesse que ce que doit apprendre à ses
clients le parcours de sportif et un peu
plus singuliers donc je vais essayer de
montrer des bd les expériences plus de
mon parcours de sportif pour bien
apprendre pour moi il ya trois questions
d'abord essentiel qu'il faut se poser
quoi qu'est ce que je veux apprendre
comment de quelle manière et avec qui
qui qui doivent enseigner ce que je veux
apprendre et c'est vrai que ces réponses
à ces questions il ya des réponses de
plus en plus nombreux avec l'innovation
notamment l'impact des technologies de
l'information et là comme des
communications mais il ya de plus en
plus de réponses potentielles et je
pense aussi que l'ordre des réponses aux
questions enfin lors des questions qu'on
se pose à un peu de lift est
potentiellement différent par rapport à
ce qu'il était avant
avant je pense que la question
principale c'était avec qui ont décidé
qu'ils voulaient qui devait être notre
entraîneur qui doit être notre formateur
et puis en fait c'était cette personne
qui décide et finalement comment et quoi
il devait nous apprendre maintenant
c'est beaucoup plus en terre change abl
alors quoi c'est vrai que avec
l'émergence d'internet et des nouvelles
technologies il ya de plus en plus
d'avoirs disponibles
ça vous vous le constatez avec wikipedia
etc et c'est un peu la même chose en
dans le sport de haut niveau il ya
toujours plus d'exigences toujours des
nouveaux éléments à prendre en patinage
artistique pour prendre cet exemple
voilà les quadruples sauts
au début des années 2000 ça existait à
peine maintenant si on a fait pas trois
dans un programme on ne peut pas être
champion du monde
donc tout ça il ya plus de plus en plus
de choses à apprendre
donc c'est plus en plus important
d'apprendre mieux et donc ça nous fait
arriver aux commandes là il ya de plus
en plus ce sera encore une fois donc de
nouvelles connaissances typiquement sur
le sur le patin artistique la médecine
du sport des techniques de préparation
mentale et c'est à qui son qui sont
arrivés qui se sont accumulés et qui ont
permis de développer de nouvelles
techniques d'apprentissage
donc ça demande aux entraîneurs et aux
athlètes d'être toujours sur en veille
et de 2 sur un petit peu ce qui se
développe et notamment donc les
technologies de l'information et des
communications j'y reviens qu' il ya des
nouvelles solutions par exemple la vidéo
en patinage artistique alors là c'est
pas moi c'est un fagot chez long que moi
je suis t3 thiais et donc c'est un
logiciel qui s'appelle dartfish qui est
vraiment de plus en plus utilisé par les
clubs les fédérations et qui permet de
décomposer les mouvements des patineurs
ça s'applique dans plein de sports
différents baseball
enfin il ya vraiment des versions pour
tous tous les sports et c'est
extrêmement intéressant
moi j'ai travaillé vie évidemment avec
ses logiciels ils m'ont fait progresser
c'est clair par contre attention parce
que c'est quand même du travail très
qualitatif
quand on quand on travaille sur un
sursaut on le regarde et le temps de le
décomposer ça peut prendre plusieurs
minutes
le haut niveau c'est pas forcément que
ça il ya beaucoup de quantitatif qe
nécessaire donc si on prend cinq minutes
pour faire un saut et d'analysés c'est
pas possible donc c'est vraiment un
outil complémentaire
idem la capture de mouvements donc là il
ya des choses c'est un peu la naïve
vidéo en plus poussée finalement et
notamment je vous conseille de regarder
cette émission miracle body par la
chaîne de télé japonaise nhk qui produit
ces documentaires d'une cinquantaine de
minutes et alors j'ai vu à l'oeuvre
notamment ils sont venus voir brian
joubert c'est un champion du monde de
patinage artistique français ils sont
venus des composés donc pendant 50
minutes d'émission il décompose son son
quadruple saut
donc ça va vraiment dans le détail il y
avait des tas de capteurs il est équipé
d'un capteur de casque
combinaison etc et ça lui a permis
vraiment progresser il ya eu des études
de fait avec l'académie de poitiers le
cnrs etc
il ya eu des reportages un peu similaire
dans plein de disciplines
donc voilà tout ça pour dire que les
techniques sont vraiment plus en plus
évoluées et ça permet aux sportifs de
progresser mais aussi c'est plus en plus
accessible maintenant je sais pas je
pense que certains d'entre vous ont la
kinect à la maison le l'outil de
microsoft est alors forcément c'est
encore un petit niveau mais ça va
permettre d' aller tout doucement vers
verser ces techniques
alors est-ce que c'est du dopage c'est
vrai que la lutte contre le dopage c'est
m tous les sportifs sur un même pied
d'égalité
bell a clairement c'est des technologies
qui sont quand même assez coûteuse est
ce que tout le monde ya accès ben non
donc forcément c'est c'est une question
qui mérite d'être posée est ce que est
ce qu'il ya dopage technologique qui
existe maintenant alors je pense que l'
avec la question mérite d'être posée
mais je pense qu'on n'a pas vraiment
réponse à ça je pense que pendant
longtemps encore ce sera la seule forme
de dopage légal avec qui voilà ça c'est
peut-être la question est ce qu'elle est
secondaire maintenant est ce que c'est
vraiment important de savoir avec qui on
va s'entraîner au mac sans parler un
petit peu il ya tous les maux qu'il ya
de plus en plus de possibilités
d'apprendre la distance j'en ai cité
quelques usines là dans le cadre du
patinage artistique online skating
school c'est un ami à moi
dow jones participants aux derniers jeux
olympiques qui a créé cette ce site
internet est en fait on peut voilà il ya
des vidéos de certains champions qui
explique sur ce site pour 5 euros
comment apprendre un élément est donc
ces méthodes commencent à se multiplier
sur internet
donc on n'a peut-être plus besoin
vraiment d'un coach en présentiel en
tout cas c'est une question qui se pose
donc ça révolutionne vraiment les
méthodes d'entraînement on peut
apprendre à distance on peut avoir un
coach qui est aux états unis qui nous
regardent un petit peu par skype ou et
qui nous donnent des conseils
ça change en tout cas ça change tout la
tête est beaucoup plus autonome et je
pense que l'étudiant également beaucoup
plus autonome dans son projet il est
plus acteur de son projet le coach aussi
donc à une approche maintenant
différente
il ya de plus en plus de savoir il peut
pas tout connaître il faut qu'il
maîtrise de nouveaux outils mais il ya
tellement de choses à savoir qui peut
pas tout maîtriser le coach pour moi il
ya deux types l'entraîneur maintenant il
y avait les entraîneurs de nice qui
vraiment maîtrise certains certains pas
vraiment spécifique d'un sport ou d'une
activité
et puis les managers qui vraiment eux
sont des partenaires des coordinateurs
des expertises alors pour autant est ce
que est ce qu'on peut se passer d'un
coach maintenant je suis persuadé que
non vraiment la technologie c'est en
complément
ça viendra jamais en remplacement j'ai
plusieurs exemples c'est vrai que
l'entraîneur est extrêmement important
dans les moments clés pour générer de la
motivation pour pour rassurer aussi
l'athlète où l'étudiant je suis persuadé
que vous avez forcément c'est chez pas
mal de cours c'était le cas à l'époque
mais vous êtes tous quasiment
systématiquement aller au dernier cours
d'un professeur parce que avant l'examen
vous aviez besoin de sentir un petit peu
ce qui ce qui ce qui vous attend dès
finalement et avoir un petit peu des
pistes pour pour être rassurés j'ai un
exemple qui est tirée là du dernier
championnat du monde
je sais pas si vous avez eu l'occasion
de regarder les championnats du monde de
patinage de la semaine dernière et donc
usereau agnew un patineur japonais
extrêmement doué plus jeune champion
olympique de l'histoire qui était le
grand favori de ce championnat du monde
mais il avait pris le il a le même
entraîneur que javier fernandez un
patineur espagnol est en fait ils auront
lieu avait décidé de faire justement sa
préparation à distance sont ils ont dix
ans le même coach donc un coach canadien
brian orser et finalement donc javier
était en présentiel en permanence depuis
le mois de janvier avec brian orser ce
n'était pas le cas de liu liu qui avait
son programme d'entraînement et qui le
travail à distance
finalement la surprise générale javier
fernandez a gagné pour moi c'est un
exemple clair que
vraiment l'entraîneur il est toujours
essentiel et restera essentiel à jamais
un autre risque avec cette technologie
d'apprentissage à distance c'est le
risque d'une uniformisation et de
standardisation sexy tout le monde
apprend à traire les mêmes vidéos les
mêmes modules en en ligne forcément tout
le monde va être assez mécanique et sa
perdra un intérêt assez énorme mais pour
moi finalement il ya une dernière
question que j'avais pas cités dans les
trois premières mais qui finalement la
plus fondamentale
c'est pourquoi si vraiment on saute
progresser et bien la réponse à cette
question à l'essentiel il faut d'abord
identifier les objectifs sous jacent
faut savoir pourquoi on a envie de
progresser et c'est vrai que c'est pas
forcément parce que typiquement pour
prendre mon exemple je n'étais pas le
plus doué des patineurs loin de là mais
mais juste j'aimais ça et j'avais envie
de progresser
j'avais tout le temps tout le temps
envie de me surpasser et du coup j'ai
réussi à battre des personnes qui
étaient bien plus bien plus doué que moi
javier fernandez pareil le champion du
monde espagnol
j'étais en stage avec lui à courchevel
pendant des années il faisait que tomber
que tomber sur des difficultés qu'ils
maîtrisent absolument pas mais il ya
toujours eu cette gnac cette motivation
sans cesse et du coup il a réussi à
franchir les étapes petit à petit parti
tout au fond des classements et puis
l'arrivée maintenant il est champion du
monde donc la motivation essentielle est
la motivation elle vient seulement à
partir du moment où on a bien réussi à
identifier ses objectifs à savoir
pourquoi on veut apprendre et enfin ne
pas hésiter à sortir de sa zone de
confort alors c'est vrai que moi quand
j'ai arrêté ma carrière de patinage en
2011 j'avais des opportunités forcément
faire de l'événementiel sportif du
coaching des choses voilà qui était
assez légitime dans la poursuite de mon
parcours parallèlement je vais
poursuivre mes études pendant en
parallèle tu
et c est en fait du coup c'est
normalement je porte des costumes mais
ils sont avec des paillettes du coup ça
me décrit un c'est tout de suite plus
facile à lire donc mais c'est vrai que
j'ai basculé vers un nouvel univers qui
complètement différent celui de la
finance est vrai que je me sentais quand
quand j'ai eu cette opportunité
a priori je me sentais pas légitime il
ya des étudiants face à moi qui depuis
depuis le début savent qu'ils veulent de
neuf qui savait qu'il voulait faire de
la finance se renseigner sur
l'entreprise sur la bouche tu sais
depuis qu'ils étaient tout petits mais
non moins j'ai eu ce challenge que j'ai
eu cette opportunité j'ai trouvé
extrêmement motivante
on m'a expliqué ce que c'était ce métier
et j'ai eu envie de le faire ça me
semblait perdue d'avancé
et ceci dit voilà j'ai eu envie j'ai eu
envie et l'envi c'est essentiel donc
donc j'ai fait tous les efforts
nécessaires pour apprendre je me suis
inscrit à des formations j'ai appris
beaucoup en ligne
j'ai je viens juste de passer un diplôme
une formation diplômante et je réfléchis
déjà la prochaine que que à laquelle je
peux m'inscrire
donc je pense que il n'ya pas de limite
vraiment quand on a envie de quelque
chose on peut y arriver et donc surtout
ne jamais ne jamais penser que la vie
est cadré et encore une fois pour
revenir à ce que disait max on en aurait
pu un peu prendre la même thématique que
lui raison passion je pense que quand
quand on a une vraie passion ça bien de
la raison aussi
donc je suis un peu stressée alors
normalement j'essaye j'essaie de
conclure en faisant une bonne chute mais
je continue donc j'ai essayé d'éviter
les accords qu'elle fasse un bide celle
là mais